okay so part of the problem is it's a
nice gonna capture your mind you guys
feel that you're like step on the knife
okay so alright so like I can come in
and hit right I don't have to capture
the knife I can come in and row wait if
you drop that knife look don't grab the
edge like this you're gonna flat grab it
you see how I'm doing that you see
there's a pocket in there then try to
make small movement fools
not many movements did see this stuff
you're too far away for Silla so small
movement
[Music]
small movements slow just keep the line
moving keep the energy movie
okay also I'm not waiting here this is
too late
so these already see how I've already
moved I want you to get used to reading
the Bond Street the body Bowl read the
bodies
[Music]
breathe breathe oh you can tell them oh
really
his body language I got this pump you
change it up right this bucket over here
Oh Peter okay let's go okay so I'm not
we're not I'm not suggesting you're not
fighting this is I'm using the tool that
will pull your mind and he's making your
payment credit okay so if if you watch
so this is a fettered - I have to mate
we go I've already moved okay I don't
need the knife I'll use this arm but if
you look at if you look at my base right
push push on me you see how I have a
base do you guys see that and my hands
are in front of me right I'm not in
these weird things okay I have a base
and I can do what I need to do
so just like standing still is the
fetter'd mind
so are these weird basics you see this
the knife pulled you out of your form so
I'm just here good incest good
connection every time every time
[Music]
no good basics
good technique right okay let's go find
your techniques okay find your ticket
here secure the arm right secure the arm
you can you still have EQ in principle
why yeah I'm on his outside why else
can you lift your elbow no do you see
that can you lift your shoulder
why can't you sitting on it right okay
and then look then I can take it take
that weapon so modification can happen
but it's modifications principle based
okay bull here see how he's in the
turtle fine sprawl out can you lift your
shoulder do you see that this is cut leg
otama in principle do you see how I'm
doing that right and so I can start
pushing the pin with my chest it's still
cutting at home and do you understand
that but don't start going like this and
you're like what is the heck is that
so modification is fine
but here's a violation of connection go
again
but I'm here you see that you're only
off you're off that's not it so
principle connection you see how I stay
on
okay principle modification principle
based modification okay everything else
is just bad basics okay so yes it's an
awareness really gets its of movement
role yes is a principle drill right okay
but let's not just get it this tactic do
you see that you can't grab things out
of there if I see you dropping the knife
I see you grabbing the wrist - okay
so pay attention to what I'm doing you
see it's a positional check do you see
that okay and then once I get his
balance I'm doing it with this hand
right in my weight shift then then I
have a trap do you see the arms on that
side but now I can grab it you see how
it's being sandwiched then I can grab it
but I can't pull it out of there you
understand if you could do that you
shooter this
okay so positional trough you see this
is a trap I got two angles on it cover
and it's fully do not blend with it and
then look I can capture it here so don't
mistake when you see me grabbing that's
a little different okay i feels away
here's the trap you see the two arms
trapping oh now i have it and now i can
grab it
so trapping is grabbing are different
things
grabbing try boom trapping here two men
grabby he dropped me okay let's go no
grabbing down in the air